a person's swinging arms can drive the  motion of his legs with a new prosthesis  in an experiment 10 healthy men were  asked to lie on their sides with their  legs suspended by wires  that allowed scientists to see subtle  leg movements caused by the prosthesis  this man is controlling his arm  movements but keeping his legs relaxed  electrodes record his shoulder muscle  activity  a computer converts those signals to  magnetic stimulation delivered to the  spine  an electrical stimulation delivered to a  nerve in the heel  because the man's lower body is relaxed  the stimulation from the prosthesis  drives his leg movement when the  stimulation stops  the man's legs stop moving even though  he continues to move his shoulder and  arm researchers are testing this  prosthesis as a way to help paralyzed  people  regain the ability to walk using their  own motion  from their arms or even a finger